cet événement estmps 2014 c'est le
premier on veut se lancer dans un cycle
annuel et notre but principal c'est de
fédérer tous les acteurs autour de la
thématique des futures acteurs ceux qui
soient un grand groupe industriel PME et
laboratoire de recherche et école de
formation aussi donc l'occasion de
rassembler c'est effectivement cette
conférence ou sur la scène on explique
les grands enjeux de la thématique et
dans la SAS ce qu'on veut c'est qu'il y
a de plus en plus d'acteurs sur tous les
PME qui se sentent concernés par la
thématique pour pouvoir apporter leur
brique technologique leur contribution
les écoles bien comprendre les enjeux de
la formation et pour les chercheurs bien
comprendre les besoins de l'industrie
pour pouvoir orienter aussi leur point
de recherche
la thématique d'une future est connue
depuis quelques quelques années déjà au
niveau de l'Europe il y a vraiment une
association européenne de recherche sur
la thématique bon ça existe depuis 2009
la France est un peu présente donc la
France doit être plus présente dans
cette association le gouvernement a
lancé le plan Nouvelle France
industrielle le point numéro 34
s'appelle l'usine du futur donc là on
est bien on est bien dans la thématique
on est bien concerné
tout est à faire et c'est les années à
venir qui vont montrer justement
l'intérêt porté par les acteurs et le
nombre d'acteurs c'est surtout ça qu'on
veut voir c'est le nombre d'acteurs
parce que aujourd'hui il y a quelques
champions il y a quelques entreprises
organisent bien compris encore faut-il
emmener d'autres dans un industriels
d'autres PME pour pouvoir travailler
ensemble
le plateau de Saclay gérer c'est une
opportunité mais il remplaçable parce
que ils sont même territoire pour
l'instant on va arriver à rassembler les
grandes écoles donc la formation on
rassemble déjà des grands élèves de
recherche le CE1 la bonne exemple et
puis aussi on a des grandes entreprises
qui sont déjà installées sur le plateau
de Saclay donc tous les grands acteurs
sont déjà là
c'est un terreau c'est à dire c'est le
plus qu'un territoire c'est un terreau
de synergie où les gens pouvoir
travailler ensemble parce qu'ils sont
proches